okay now we're black
once again i'm i'm going to play some
trash normally
i'm going to spoil some real ideas
let's see what he wants here okay g4
knight f6
let's play this knight c6 line
which is called the rouser variation i
guess
and g6 yeah i think i played it many
times in the magnus store
the line is not brilliant but okay there
is nothing to hide here anymore i played
it like a billion of times
yeah bishop d7
bishop g7
[Music]
then you normally go bishop e6 i believe
hoping for knight d4 bishop d7 goes to
f4 yeah then we i guess castle and f
takes and we place this position
queen d2 okay
this does not look too smart to me to be
honest but it kind of makes sense
obviously
so normally when you don't know what to
do in this lines you go with five
let's hope this is not uh
this is not where we should not do this
rog one well this is this allows knight
d4 at released
okay let's play knight d4 feels very
very natural to activate the knight
um yeah then we'll probably go rox8 one
day and
you know white is probably slightly
better but uh
there is not much going on i guess so
bishop takes he wants bishop d3
and he wants to trade uh the bishops
which is probably a decent idea but okay
we cannot really prevent this
we actually have some queen g5 here that
is a bit annoying for him
queen of three check is a threat after
king h1
we can probably
we can probably even consider knight xc2
or at least bishop to xd3
and then we play an engine okay i think
queen g5 is fine
um yeah i can get you one let's think
he'll play
i could also just play bishop g4 just to
avoid um
trade of bishops so now it's kind of
less smart because of 94.
although we will have some ideas there
as well so what about knight takes c2
first of all
h4 does not work uh bishop takes a five
quintex f5
95 doesn't does not look great
okay then i guess we'll just play it
simple we just take
uh take on g2
and probably we just go look see
so now if you manage to you know make
some knight d5 work then he'll be
better so we need to try to prevent this
uh this thing from happening
goes rook d1 this allows
bishop h6 in uh maybe
even better version for us
okay let's play bishop h6 let's uh you
know make sure he plays the four then we
just go back
then if we'll have to we we can even
sacrifice the d6 pawn
and once again this should not be much
for white and i would say black is just
fine
i think he has to try an id5 at some
point like rook takes c2 and then he
just plays for
this activity like takes takes rook c1
rook c7 and so on
he goes knight c1 wow that's why he's
great
i could not see this coming okay okay it
doesn't look bad to me
so there is no rook to xd4 he has to
probably
make a lift it goes 93
back wow was it on d3
and i guess it was yeah okay
so now we have to yeah to improve
somehow maybe we just go with five yeah
i mean if he wants to skip moves we
should not prevent him
from doing so okay g3
so is it time to play b5 for 95 maybe
95 he he gets his 95
maybe we just go b5 and then
then it's probably weak pawn on b5 yeah
okay let's just play 6 just to play move
now it's probably safer to go b5 also
it's not ideal anyway okay let's play
rook c4
maybe we can play knight f5 one day and
after 95 we want some rook g4
some 93 check isn't there
we can also just double okay so he plays
this one knight to 5 95 rook d4
what's the idea knight before we just go
just go a5 maybe now okay let's try this
maybe what i'm doing is wrong in general
because i'm provoking him
to play knight d5 and if it works it's
uh
it's an improvement for white obviously
so as always we are relying on some
tricks that
that might not work maybe they do work i
don't know
so knight before i'm going to play five
he takes on d4 i play knight takes
and then i take on c2 yeah i mean it
seems to work
maybe he has something here okay he goes
there
giving giving up the beetle pawn
basically
okay i guess we take it ah he wants c3
that's why we probably take on d5 and
then we go
93 knight takes d5 and bishop to xb2
now we're ripping up once again i think
we managed to play the guy
but it's not yet um
not yet good enough for a win i'm afraid
should i include rook street shank
might make sense okay let's just take
and 94. yeah that's what i was worried
about so he's uh
going to sacrifice the h2 pawn for some
or some peace activity how should i play
this i can just go roxy7 back actually
this is kind of a chicken move but at
least it uh gives me some kind of
stability here
so he wants to trade well wait we have
rook c6 take stakes king e4 king of
faking d4 king e7 king c5 king d7 king
b6
does it worth does it work for him it's
a miracle if it does to be honest
okay we can start with the check
king judo okay now rook c6 should work
now
i mean once again maybe he holds this
but then it's a miracle i would say
if he will save it this way okay i'll be
impressed
okay king of fade
king is seven so what's the what's the
plan
f5 doesn't seem to change much okay
let's see king d6
then we go c5
okay he resigns